how you doing
let's make that a workout and I got to
do 15 of them it's a workout you've
scoured the city for the hottest new
Fitness disciplines these are the
workouts everyone's talking about
we've got turf set white-eye tabata yoga
and boot camp it's your body
this is fighting all right Tyler and I'm
an aside one more time
this is your at-home white tie
upper-body workout so what are we doing
today
muy Thai upper body workout is kind of
like any other upper body workout
basically just designed to give you a
little more strength a little more
conditioning a little more endurance you
know help tighten up your movement and
to also give you the feeling what it
feels like when you're in the middle of
a fight when you're really banging your
muscles are pumped up to still be able
to execute those moves so what we're
going to do here is you're going to take
this around you okay okay you know wrap
it around we're going to come through is
going to be a little tight and you're
going to grab the hands on the inside
now what you'll do is you'll put your
hands in your fighting stance here we're
going to our fighting stance and now you
have the concept pull and push okay it's
a good thing about the band's is is it
as you feel it kind of forces you to
keep your hands up yes it holds you in
position but what I want to constantly
be doing is as I move and breathe it
just and you'll feel the constant
tension now in your arms and your
shoulders will be in your biceps yeah
okay even triceps yep the whole upper
body and then you can even brought drop
down into a push-up position and do a
push-up with the band so we drop down on
one knee I put my hands where my hands
are down in front of me and not out in
front of me and then we'll just do a
regular push but will you come down and
press back up gonna get a little easier
as you go down the little harder as you
come up okay okay the other one we can
take the band off and if you don't have
something you can wrap the band around
you can basically stand on the band here
right so the wider you go the harder
you're going to make it now you're going
to keep both your elbows tucked in by
your side right and we're just gonna
basically squeeze up good and come down
nice and slow
up and down shoulders should be back
chest should be out you should be
working on squeezing the peak of that
bicep right now we're doing this we're
gonna have the band moving and your
bicep moving your upper body should not
be going forward back side to side your
chin should not be looking for anywhere
about doing the punches with the band's
the push-ups the curls and the presses
you pretty much hit your whole upper
body with just one band okay you also
have something like let's say uh you
know a chair or something you can almost
do like a chest wha turnout and press
and press and it's almost like I'm doing
a push except for now I'm doing like a
standing chest press bring your hands in
here elbows come forward just like
you're doing a chest press right here
actually that's straight forward and
come straight back nice and control just
like that
your plaintiff resistance is right
across the middle of your chest almost
like you're doing a bench press but
standing you want to do a little more of
an incline press you can bring your
hands up a little bit
same thing now that way you won't even
modify even more you could turn your
wrists elbows in and come straight back
and press straight forward now you'll be
working a little morbid deltoid your
tricep your upper shoulders awesome
that's great stuff going to appreciate
it so to recap guys we started off in
this case with a minute worth of the
punches with the band's moved into a
minute or two push-ups then we went to a
minute to finish up with the curls is a
bonus you can go in and find a pole or
something to wrap this around and do
some chest press begin the good thing
about this is you can throw a variety of
punches you can curl a variety of
different ways the movements are pretty
much infinite you can work on different
areas of your body right with this one
little thing so no excuses guys this is
a good one right here thank you nope
well make sure to subscribe so you don't
miss out on any other fighting weight
episodes
you